dude I love popcorn bro I don't how is
it it's not a vegetable but no other i
mean corn is but no other think about it
no other vegetable can do that trick
that corn does and just say BAM you know
if you look at a thing a corn you don't
know that that magic is in there you
don't know nobody if you know if you
know 500 years ago or even 200 years ago
they gave you know maybe 70 people if
they they asked 70 people write down
what do you think is inside of this corn
I bet none of them right
sheer damn joy magic snack popcorn
that's the thing they don't know what's
in there they don't know
they don't know what's in the kernel
they don't know you know people there's
not a you can't always see the magic you
can't always see that magic and good I'm
boy good hanger rang you can hello you
can't tell me dude if you put five or
six little popcorns in your hand you
can't even feel it
that's how beautiful a little just a
little creature that's a little snack a
source and you just let that popcorn
climb in your mouth and it's crunchy and
it's naughty to some of it it's strong
and some of its it pops a little when
you eat it get yeah oh boy
but nobody knows the magic that's in
there the people can't you know they
just they don't know the magic that can
be inside of of us people don't know it
you know sometimes you just you can't
judge a vegetable bias by its cover
really you really really can't let's go
and we don't even have any intro music
today because why I forgot my computer
and that's how we do it we hook it up
and and I forgot it I just got back in
from Sacramento and I in Las Vegas and
today's episode though I got to tell you
if your junk is getting kind of
whiskering sometime you pull down your
pants and you you know when you got you
you got that little you know the fellas
they got that note that are they got
that though it looked like a little long
anteater they got that ante or it starts
to get a little like it's been um hiding
in the woods it gets a little mangy got
you got a lot of hair a lot of whiskers
looks like you like your wieners been
kind of going to see fish concerts or
maybe eatin grilling cheese and sand I
love a grilling cheese and if you
haven't had one of these just my god
it's like somebody just took two squares
of bread
and just just it's like the Lord just
licked each square of bread and just and
just put them bad little bastards
together and if you put two beautiful
pieces of bread together long enough bro
they do that then make that grill and
cheese in between them but yeah
sometimes your wiener if you haven't
taken care of it it looks like it looks
like it's you know been out in the yard
it looks like it hasn't been doing stuff
you know you got a manicure it and
that's why support for this past weekend
comes from manscaped manscaped is number
one in men's below-the-belt grooming
look you don't want to take off your
pants and yes you know and your area
looks like a like a bunch you know like
the like somebody hadn't hired somebody
to do any maintenance you know sometime
you'll see a guy he trimmed one of it
you know one half of his junk and the
other half you know looks like a damn
riverbank and you're like what they even
got a couple trout lines coming off of
it that's not the way to do it fellas so
manscaped offers precision engineered
tools for your family jewels and I and
look they got a beautiful they got this
one tool it's called the the plow in the
plow you can really oh man
I mean you feel like an indentured
servant out there just whacking these
hairs away it's real real medieval
manscaped is forever changing the
grooming game with their perfect package
2.0 inside the perfect package you'll
find their electric trimmer called the
lawnmower 2.0 now 99% of the time I say
as I always do
do not put a lawnmower near your nuts
and near your body you know don't mow a
new yard with your pants down that's
brave as hell if you see somebody mowing
naked with a push mower don't call the
cops man pop some champagne because as a
man having your nuts out that close to a
spinning blade I mean there's your bet
you chance Armstrong right there because
you're taking a real you really put an
opportunity a risky opportunity on the
line but uh but the the lawn mower 2.0
it's it's waterproof its skin safe
technology it'll protect you from
nicking your sack you can also create
less mess by trimming in the shower now
that's beautiful
a lot of things you can't use that you
can't use a you know that electrical
deal in the shower so let's not forget
about the crop preserver it's an anti
chafing ball deodorant and moisturizer
because you want that soft badge you
don't want to show up with them mom you
know them Chips Ahoy really them hard
them you know in a couple moles on your
balls you want them you want that soft
batch so you got to moisturize that bag
and of course let's not forget about
that crop preserver you already put
deodorant on your armpits why are you
not putting deodorant rania newts bra
it's time to get clean with the perfect
package 2.0 get 20% off from manscaped
and free shipping with the code Theo
th EO at manscaped com always use the
right tools for the job your balls will
thank you get
20% off and free shipping with the code
Theo at manscape comm that's 20% off
with Free Shipping at manscape calm and
I'll do a thing I'll bend over because a
lot of hair will gather kind of between
my legs almost along that back strap and
if you ever died in a plane crash
something that a lot of people would eat
or cook off of you is that area
sadly between you know that behold a bag
jaw and your nuts and the bass line your
nut saying where your nuts really just
kind of start where because really your
nuts just at the top of your nut sack is
just your body so they you know your
body just kind of turns any or nuts but
um but anyway what I'm saying I think
Jesus I don't even know is that um that
I get down there and they'll have a
whole bunch of hair we'll get right
there and I'll get right there with that
or with the different tools that they
offer at manscaping and really clean huh
clean up my package especially if you're
going through a divorce you're single
you know you love somebody you know you
were seeing somebody during a coma now
you got to get back out there
so freshen up your batch you know but
you ain't that interesting about corn
you would never think it if you look at
it you would never think the magic that
could be in there you would never a man
I go to you know we've been going to the
Children's Ronald McDonald Children's
Center and doing moving out on Tuesday
nights and man seeing all the kids they
handicaps some of them and they got you
know uh you know IVs going in their arms
and you know and there's some of them
are met you know their body they have a
deformity but man you break that popcorn
out Manny
some of them don't even have a full
faintly five fingers in a tienes but
they suddenly every hand looks the same
when they reach them for that magic
but you don't know a man you don't know
the magic that's in a kernel man and
people know the magic that's inside of
us are inside of you they don't know it
but I believe that we all have something
special in us uh you know I'm feeling
I'm feeling pretty good man I had some
good shows this weekend just got back
from Las Vegas literally just got back
about an hour and a half ago and and man
it was fun if you were at that show whoo
people came out people came out and we
had a mother-daughter that came out this
woman Dorothy and her dog her and her
daughter came out and man it just really
makes me feel good I see the see some
family connections you know to just see
a mother and daughter enjoying something
together and and even though it happens
to be my comedy or that there or my you
know I'm part of their evening just to
see them doing something special
together and caring about each other
it makes me feel good man it makes me
feel like I'm on the right track that
were on the right track by doing this
this Lowell this group that we're doing
knew we had a father son and mother come
out and in Sacramento the young guy is
uh he's a he does backflips and
gravity-defying activity you know dark
arts I call it really you know he worked
he do he does he works on a scooter and
does that kind of stuff and they came
out we had a father-son that came on in
Sacramento you know we had a guy who
came up to me in Vegas and he said hey
maybe you shouldn't you got to stop
being so hard on yourself
and I really resonated with that guy
just telling me that and and and people
tell me that a lot and sometimes I can't
hear it
and that's kind of funny in that funny
song we can't heat like 70 people will
tell you the same thing
but for some reason on the 53rd time
there's somebody kind of breaks through
whatever is going on with you and and
you're in a moment where you're able to
accept it and I had a little bit of that
man and and I just yeah I woke up this
morning think I'm you know every what if
everything is okay what if I quit this a
little dirty circle in my head and
everything is just okay and then that
made me really feel good and but yeah a
lot of great people want to thank
everybody that came out in Sacramento
over there and and in um Las Vegas
and in Las Vegas man they had some real
drunks out there boy they had one dude
at the end of the night he was on they
had like a little in the hotel it's
probably ought to a.m. they had a I
don't know what it was it was like a
well he thought it was a wishing well
and it wasn't it was like a um just a
like a like a wall where they had some
water going down it and it was like a
like just you know part of the scenery
in the casino they you know sometimes
you'll go over a little bridge and and
this dudes sitting there that's making
wishes off this [ __ ] I was like dang
brah that ain't even that's just a you
know justice OA that's just like some
design and [ __ ] you wishing on what are
you wishing for bucko so anyway I forgot
my computer that's what happens here we
are here we are what else what else
happened this weekend Oh oh my back went
out I had to go to Urgent Care literally
right when I got home I drove straight
to Urgent Care man I'm back this morning
I'm putting my shoe on next thing you
know look like somebody yelled freeze
remember freeze tag
somebody yell freeze you just had to
stop from the waist up that's what I was
doing just buckled down boy just buckled
down yeah and that was it man
everything's pretty cool everything's
pretty chill
I think but I'm gonna need some help I
don't have my computer this episode so
we're gonna get Nick in here
our lovely producer pretty much
premature Nick's gonna come in so he can
help talk about the questions and things
like that and we'll just have a little
change of pace for today we got
Sebastian Maniscalco coming in as a
guest this week and that guy he's so
Italian isn't he okay that's what he
says all the time okay yeah no that's
not it okay dude always thinking they
should have more animals right how many
animals do they have seventy animals
like that's sometimes Maya that's one of
my issues what God is brah bake another
batch daddy you know you got all the
capabilities you got you know I'd love
to see like kind of a unicorn that has
Wi-Fi in its horn that's got that
[ __ ] hard hitter on the top that
router wouldn't that be great you can't
get Wi-Fi but suddenly one of these you
corn shows up and to think about a
unicorn that's another thing you don't
notice how much magic is in it that's
another type of corn
if dude imagine
first unicorn walks up you know somebody
shot that [ __ ] down right on us and I
mean in no offense man but somebody
really popped that cat down boy if you
saw a unicorn show up you were like damn
boy I mean there's no way you couldn't
think this horse is trying to [ __ ] boy
this horse is trying to in the but you
know this horse is in the dark arts
there's no way you couldn't think that
but it's interesting how much magic is
in a unicorn
they're probably top six magic animals I
think anyway if you had to think about
it I don't know what we're talking about
uh but yeah Majan that first unicorn
rolls up do you sitting there with your
buddy maybe you guys are having a couple
garbanzo beans or you know trying to get
rid of yellow fever or whatever I don't
know I don't even know what year it was
when they showed up and next thing you
know this bad [ __ ] rolls up with that
bad a half with that freaking that top
piece baby a unicorn is basically like a
shark it's like the shark of horses and
but they got magic in them man you never
know how much magic is in a unicorn by
looking at it you just think damn this
horse is really honestly probably trying
to meet some local men
you know we're trying to do or trying to
pick a lock or something or what else
are trying to just you know push a
button on an elevator or what else I
don't even know what a horse would do
with that horn on its head you know hang
out just maybe hang laundry but like
just one shirt
but you don't realize when you see that
Unicorn how much how much power is in
them and how much magic full of magic
you just don't know man people don't
know they don't know the magic that we
might have inside of ourselves they
really really don't know
let's get Nick in here because I need
some help getting through this episode
sometimes we need some help and I don't
like asking for help you know I don't
like it I don't like asking for help man
I don't like I like to do stuff myself
but I can't do that every day bro and
I'm not gonna do it right now I'm gonna
keep the vibe going we got a good vibe
we're cruisin it's Monday you're here
I'm here they had to earthquake in Bali
I saw on Twitter so imagine that let's
shake [ __ ] up bruh
mother nature's out there making that
mix cocktail brah she's shaking it up
let's see what we can do we'll be right
back actually Nick you want to come on
in premature Nick what's going on I'm on
time yeah you're on time brother how are
you yeah good I'm Sean yeah how was uh
how was your trip it was it was good man
it was fast and it was good it was one
show at night so it's a little bit of a
different vibe like less pressure to
like hurry up and get for this get to
the second show regroup
yeah yeah yeah it was time to regroup
but yeah it was good man it was a good
experience man yeah man thanks for
steppin in dude I'm sorry I forgot my
computer it's all good it's all good
we got multiple here so yeah good man oh
yeah let's get into some of the calls
and um and then if you have some news
stuff let's let's uh change the vibe a
little bit today cool cool yeah this
first one we had a couple people calling
about this the Sacramento sound like the
Sacramento people got a little rowdy oh
yeah yeah they had a couple
well here look they got a call yep all
right hey Theo this is coming from
Sacramento big Tony show big Tony thank
you for calling in this and Tony short
for Anthony I guess what else you think
big Tony maybe those are pretty much
Antonio Antonio yep there you go
Spanish Tony um onward I was at your
show last night such a later show last
night and then I just don't feel very
good about my city we were kind of rude
to you I think and and I gotta tell like
like five people to shut up and it was
distracting and I had on the balcony
seats and throughout the whole show
there wasn't a single time when anyone
was just sitting down and trying to
adjust watching the show trying to enjoy
it any given point for the whole damn
thing dude there was like at least two
or three people milling about if not
more it was distracting it was hard to
enjoy your show and if it was
distracting for me I can only imagine
how distracting it was for you so we
were not very nice to you that that
night enough I want to apologize man and
I hope you still want to come back and
see us yeah man well look I appreciate
the call yeah that's that the Friday
night show that was there was yes some
guy was yelling he kept yelling out and
one point he's yelling I think it like
one of his wives her son I don't know
what was going on he might have been
Saudi Arabian and they carry a couple
wives like you'll ask a Saudi like a
Saudi Raven girl reach in his pocket and
if I can accidentally drop a couple
wives out you know but you know what I
did notice that there were constantly
people just walking around
I mean Sacramento also let's be honest
dude it's got that sort of a lot of
missing people kind of you know like a
lot of a lot of missing people are in
Sacramento so I'm amazed sometimes that
more people don't know that so if you're
missing somebody go there and that's
where they are I mean it's a lot of
people you've seen on posters and stuff
there in Sacramento
missing animal Sacramento can't find my
has anybody seen my wallet
Sacramento it's all there man and I just
feel bad for the people that's have to
show this trying to enjoy themselves you
know that's the part that gets me a
little bit but but uh but thank you for
the call man you know it gets what I
don't what makes it tough for me is that
I want people to enjoy the show and so
if somebody's all wasted and they're
just acting like a donkey then that
really it doesn't help so I'm trying to
keep the show kind of undone key and
keep it tight but I appreciate the call
Tony even though that guy said that and
there were a couple other people that
called in about some of the rowdy
members in the crowd everybody said they
still like really enjoyed the show and
you killed and it didn't infect their
time this guy he was in the balcony a
little further away but most people said
they just had an amazing time it's still
a great show they're just like some
people can't act right gang yeah you
know it's funny and I think we learned
that as we go along it's like you know
somebody always can't act right and it
is what it's like and that but that's
just what it is you know and I got to
learn also to just vibe better with it
you know I can't control everything
that's going to happen some people just
aren't going to act right sometimes
fortunately we were able to you know
some of the people to toss them out and
then get back on and then get the wheels
back going but what's tough for me is
that there's a good flow to the show and
if it's really flowing and somebody gets
really donkey doubt then it you know it
kind of kicks the whole show in the ass
a little so but thank you for your call
Tony I appreciate it man here's a
patreon question actually this along the
same lines and this is Kara she said how
do you keep yourself amped up for your
tour performances when you're doing the
same thing so often so many times for
different people
yang Thank You Kara for your support on
patreon and and for this question um
you know it's been tough and I've
actually been talking to other comedians
about it you know I was talking to
Sebastian Maniscalco about it the other
day and and just asking him you know how
do you keep the material fresh and
because I was having some trouble with
it a little bit this year especially the
shows in New York City I was really just
burnt out like I don't want to just get
up there and be like a record player
something that just kind of starts and
just goes through the stuff you don't
want to be in the moment I want it to be
kind of feel like a new experience for
the people and uh and and and I just got
reminded of that actually the past two
weeks I just started thinking mana you
know I have to have fun in what I'm
doing you know and I've noticed that for
myself over this year even just
sometimes I'm just not enjoying it but
it's just because I'm not making that
choice like it's up to me if I have fun
or not that's up to me you know life's
gonna throw curveballs and sliders and
sometimes just gonna run up it's just
gonna run all the way from the pitchers
man and just put a ball right in your
ass - not even a pitch like what is that
but it's like you it's it's how I choose
how I meet the world and it's almost the
same thing for these shows it's like I
choose if I if I just get caught up in
letting things just run in a circle and
I don't try to show up and just
recognize hey tonight is a new
experience we could have a new joke come
out of this evening we could have a new
moment we can embrace what's going on we
could talk about what's happening in the
city
like I actually started off the show I
didn't realize this in Vegas with you
know Oread went up before me and there
was another real funny young fella named
Bruce that went up and I was like man
it's nice to have two white guys in a
theater without guns huh
and and it was funny it was crazy but I
didn't realize it but it got a big laugh
out of the beginning and it got
everybody kind of in the vibe and I
didn't know that was gonna happen but I
was gonna say that
but some of the stories I just try and
keep my attitude open like hey like like
I'm telling it to a friend for the first
time hey let me have fun telling this
because even though it's maybe the
hundredth time I've told some of them
this the first time you're gonna hear it
and so if I make it not about myself and
I make it about the people that are
there you know hey this is their first
time to hear this
that helps now with that said it does
get hard to do it over and over again it
gets hard some jokes it's like the
punchline and almost it's like
screeching out of you don't even want it
to feel any want to say it what was some
of the advice from Sebastian Sebastian
suggesting then you kind of change it
huh he's like you know change it doing
it
I think that's noses old advice huh why
do you say it Sebastian he told me he
was taking adult swim lessons but he'll
be on here this week and I'm gonna bring
this out a question back up with him
Cara Nick if you'll remind me to help do
that will do let's take another call
what came in so last week we had the
gentleman called in he actually had two
voicemails the first one he was feeling
pretty down feeling overwhelmed by all
of us do it loans he called in and said
he had a better attitude about it but we
got some some responses to your advice
to him - just like ride it out pay as
low as you can keep lowering the
payments and we got some responses of
that okay cool yeah that's this is
pretty uh I'm curious to see what some
people thought Thanks
here's the first one photo video this is
Tyler from Birmingham Alabama going game
you know getting game brother I'll see
you next week man August 15th at the
stardome so for that but anyway I wanted
to call about the guy who had a who was
kind of down on himself about the
student loan debt yes some good points a
couple things that I've heard one
student loan debt is the best line of
credit to have
so you know it's not a bad thing to have
on your on your credit line and you can
make the minimum payments you don't
there's no time line in order to pay it
back
and I have an old friend that told me
one time that uh
you know if you if you die before you
pay it all back then you win
so I mean no rush to pay all that [ __ ]
back
that's hilarious dude
yeah if that's the case go get your
masters buddy bear um that's a good
suggestion what do you think about that
Nate yeah I mean I'm kind of of two
minds like it it doesn't hurt your
credit score it's not gonna hurt you
like eating a house or whatever but part
of me is like oh you took out an
agreement you should work to pay it back
even we look as like the government oh
they're not gonna miss it but still like
just part of me is like you should honor
your debts yeah wow man it's very um I
haven't been doing it I had stark of you
very Ned Stark move when it comes to uh
well you haven't been doing it though
yeah yeah I've been doing the whole push
it off push it off I mean it was always
I would do the things they they look at
your income so the lawyer payments and
I've been doing doing that whole thing
but now that now I'd like to start
chipping away at at least or at least
make their regular minimum payments to
get on some type of foreseeable plan
where it's getting paid off but I would
feel like an idiot if they get wiped
away yeah I mean companies do you know
it is interesting how we all think are
sometimes we think like yeah just
because it's a big company or it's the
government it's like we don't really owe
them mm-hmm it's almost like this
invisible thing it just keeps forward
that will just keep working mm-hmm and
that yeah we don't think sometimes like
that we made this Agreement like we
clicked on the square or whatever and
filled it in and said submit and you're
using whatever they gave us or you know
and then and then we when it comes to a
later or it's like ah [ __ ] it's like
almost so it will we forget that would
that yeah we we put our name on the line
you know that we have some integrity in
it
it's interesting man I definitely could
say that ever in my life I remember the
first cell phone bill ever got it was
for like seven thousand dollars right I
didn't realize you couldn't just use
your phone as once you want I thought I
got this [ __ ] man I had a hundred
minutes okay like a hunter Menace my
cell phones came out it was just enough
minutes to really realize you don't you
you cannot afford a cell phone man every
call you had to be like hey it was
almost like you were in that movie where
you have like there's like a timer and
it's gonna blow up or something so it
was like every call that came in or
you'd have to try and get it you
remember they used to like I've read it
about fifty seconds you'd be looking
like alright man we got a my first cell
phone plan I was late to the game cuz I
had to pay for my own cell phone high
school was was unlimited they had
already moved into those types of tight
plans it was it was a benefit of waiting
but yeah I mean my grandma was always
worried about her minutes man she would
nights and weekends that that's what I
do week is boy live like look man I
can't call you know after 9:00 yeah so
if you had a friend that was in any
other timezone as a kid you was [ __ ]
he was not friends anymore
did you before cell phones play the
collect call game I would I would have
to collect call to go get picked up and
yes I'd be at the Y and it'd be a it's
Nick I'm done and my grandma would come
and pick me up 15 minutes later yeah man
that was awesome that was always a good
move and the movie theater game like
they had to click over so how if I was
gonna have a probably gonna have a girl
call me back late at night I would say
okay you know at about 9:20 i'ma call a
movie theater line because they had like
a 40-minute message on there and it was
like now showing this weekend at 7 The
Bodyguard starring Whitney Houston and
Kevin Costner show times are Monday
through Friday 5 p.m. and 7 p.m.
Saturday matinee 2 p.m. and 4:30 p.m.
Saturday and Sunday evening 5 7 & 9 p.m.
then it would be like now showing in
theatres too and then it would go on to
the next movie you know Land Before Time
Wow this young dinosaur doesn't know
what's going to occur starring the
voices of you know Lou Diamond Phillips
and it would just keep going it still be
like a 40-minute message so if you had
that call waiting then you could hear
someone calling you the beep and it
wouldn't ring in your house gosh yeah so
be like alright I'm just gonna call the
movie theater and hope she called now
sometimes your girl would fall asleep
you know because [ __ ] be rest and
everybody knows that though if you go
looking at 9:00 [ __ ] probably about
two of them dress ting so then you just
heard the entire movie three or four
times and then in my dream that night it
was just the background loop it was just
just me eating popcorn you know mm-hmm
what was this question what was this
about he was just kind of reiterating
your sentiment about the student loans
just yeah keep dragging it out yeah keep
dragging it out that's a good but also
yeah the the thing we forget so though
sometimes it yeah we made a deal you
know we did make a deal I mean big
companies do get kind of fun everybody
just thinks they can [ __ ] them mm-hmm
but they also [ __ ] people every chance
they get probably goes unnoticed but
that doesn't mean we have to act like
that right right
yeah minutes it's a real battle god I
remember
oh I remember I'd send letters to
Verizon like man [ __ ] y'all bruh you
know I remember sending pictures of me
from photographs of me with like this
with my hands in the air holding my
pockets out like I have no money
I would $7,000 dude so and somebody oh I
remember this was the worst somebody
kept calling me from Africa brah and I
don't know how they got my number
I don't know how Africa even got a phone
at this point like I didn't know they
had even had a phone in Africa but they
kept calling me and I would get charged
when I answered it you know did you guys
talk huh did you guys talk yes sometimes
it was so hard to know what's going on
bro Africa
I mean Africa is pretty wild and imagine
Africa on the phone maybe it was that
you don't say if Africa cauldre I'm not
saying don't answer brother you know
maybe you know just maybe don't answer
every time
exactly let's take another call man all
right this one is who is listening oh
good you're always asking who's
listening see oh my man it's a boy Bo
from Indiana big Bo Indiana dude and
that is uh that is Spanish for Indian
first of all and also beautiful place
dude you know sorta hit or miss out
there in the middle of America dude a
lot of good people out there you know a
lot of vaudeville used he was in Indiana
a lot of young that have children
learning to juggle and do a lot of
stunts a lot of stunt people come out of
that area it's a real stunt country so
you know you'll see a [ __ ] newborn
you know go back into its mom and try
and get shot out of her you know I'm
saying a lot of people doing real kind
of artsy stuff onward working that
graveyard shift as a County deputy
trying to fight that crime that gr baby
shoot them we're - thank you for your
entertainment during my downtime man
gets kind of slow out here I've also
been tuning in the King and sing your
boy Brendan isn't too bad of a fella man
you guys make a good combo that kind of
reminds me of a Nick Jonas that that
stuff taken out of Hesh you fill me okay
see ya
yeah Nick Jonas that stop taking adipex
yeah I'm not sure oh he looks like him I
see you're saying yeah yeah yeah burnin
has a very rare rare look man one of the
best things ever heard about Brandon I
read this on uh on comments somewhere
Brendan looks like the kind of guy that
rides with both of his legs off the same
side of a horse I like the one at one of
the first rows my host on king of the
sting one of the segments you guys do on
that show it was he looks like a Puerto
Rican baseball coach that's always
flexing his assets I seen that dude
whisper into his pants before so you
know there's some hectic going on thank
you thank you for your service out there
deputy and I think look man nighttime
middle of the night after 2:00 a.m. to
4:00 a.m. you guys should get a
the free bullets out there you know what
I'm saying pop off a couple times right
now because here's the thing if you
shoot a bullet up in an air in the
distance and it just hit someone that's
on the Lord bruh you know if it hits
somebody man in the Indiana in Rowlett
yeah that Indiana Roulette baby
Popoff daddy stay safe out there brother
and thank you for the call
you know I was thinking before you came
in here man I was talking I was thinking
about potential do you whenever you're
growing up did you feel like get a lot
of potential neck or what
what does potential mean if I think
about that what does it mean yeah just
the ability to do more than what you're
currently doing kind of and I always
thought I did yeah I was always really
unsure of what I was gonna try but like
I just felt like when I compared myself
to other people I was just like I'm
better or I like that's better but I
would see people in positions where they
are is like well I could do that
titin kind of at least right cuz that's
a good point I could do that at least
right so I have potential to do that
maybe more than that or something yeah
or an advanced state of that mm-hmm
you had has been thinking I was thinking
about potential earlier and just like
where does like potential come from or
what is it you know we'll look at what
you mind looking at a potential I'm
gonna think about it real quick yeah st
a bit you could because people that's
one thing that people I mean I guess
people can recognize your potential
people say that a lot you know or you
know you'll hear that term or recognize
your potential Oh what does it say
brother having or showing the capacity
to become or develop into something in
the future hmm yeah cuz let's leave our
pop corners we're gonna do this and how
you don't have no think about that David
of popcorn you would never guess it's in
there mm-hmm you would never guess it
dude
if you looked at it if you look
a corn bro and you wrote down 200 things
it could be in there none of them would
be popcorn all the things I wrote down
would be smaller than what's right so
that's kind of potential you know yeah
man I guess that you know what's funny I
guess I see potential in people I guess
if you see put if you could it's really
kind of cool if you can see if you do
see if you see potential in somebody
that's kind of like a neat way to look
at people I think I'm I don't do it all
the time for sure I'll forget about it a
lot but looking for somebody's potential
[Music]
yeah wonder if you have to I wonder if
potential is something that other people
have to say oh I feel like you have
potential or if somebody tells you that
it definitely makes you feel good yeah
that's a big compliment or that's a big
thing because it makes you feel
motivated that you can do more I think a
lot of potential is mindset and you can
get that mindset from like other people
reinforcing it but I'm telling you and
then you're like oh I can do this and so
then you give an attempt at it but like
if you don't I think that's why like
there's kind of like a malaise in like
poor neighborhoods or whatever people
don't think they have the potential to
escape but when someone from their area
ends up succeeding there they see oh
that's possible for me too and it opens
up a world of possibilities yeah yeah
that potential when you see somebody
doing something and it makes you feel
like oh I can do that I could be that
guy yeah it almost ignites a part of you
that's wonderful in the future it'll be
a medicine that or something that that
makes your potential kind of flare up
you know or just remind you that you
have it I guess I need to just remember
that just trying to notice people's
potential more yeah I don't think I do a
good job of that sometimes I think I
could probably do better because I think
if you let people know man you have a
lot of potential you know I really see
this potential you even call out things
they do that really makes people feel
good huh yeah you know when people do
that I've noticed just in my own life
when people say that especially like if
an older person says that to you when
you're young
and stuff may have someone you have
someone's potential you know I really
see so much potential in you anyway
yeah I was just thinking about popcorn
earlier let me say this man internet
privacy is basically dead uh yeah I mean
I look at porn for instance did you know
that the the UK government passed a law
requiring you to hand over your ID
before you can access porn sites oh
Jesus sure your [ __ ] Nick if you go
abroad bro but here you're just watching
[ __ ] and you're still okay that's
right like your driver's license or
passport dude that would be crazy if you
had to put something on the line every
time you went to watch porn about a lot
less people would do it it's only a
matter of time before your government
gets the same idea and what happens when
your favorite porn site gets hacked like
Ashley Madison did all those names and
IDs will be floating around waiting to
get published on the web and I'm gonna
let everyone know right now that I've
been on a decent amount of porn sites
not very much in the last year you know
the dark arts have really quit drawing
themselves in front of me in that in
that area but I've definitely looked at
some naughty stuff on there you know
certainly a lot of female on female a
lot of butt stuff probably and even some
double butt and so I just want to let
people know what I've done in case
anything ever comes out but what I'm
saying right now is that you have to
protect your internet usage with
expressvpn accessing the internet with
expressvpn means the websites you visit
won't know where you're coming from they
shield your identity expressvpn is the
best way to make your online activity
anonymous and it's the VPN provider that
I trust to protect my data and I'll say
this when I was in when I was in China I
had to use a VPN access the internet to
access sites that I wanted to to sneak
around so the government didn't see you
trying to do it so you couldn't get in
trouble you can use Express VPN every
time you go online and you should
download the Express VPN app on your
computer or phone push one button and
voila you're protected for less than
seven dollars a month you can get the
same Express VP
protection that I have expressvpn is
rated the number one VPN service by
TechRadar and comes with a 30-day
money-back guarantee it's definitely
time I mean I worry a lot of times
nikidik I'll think man here they go
I do wanna know that years from now all
of our truth is gonna come out like the
things we look at you know the things
we've seen the things we've googled
jeepers man you know
jeepers man I mean I I should do one day
that's all the things that I've googled
and how I feel about them them it's time
to stop Big Brother and surveillance of
your online activity protect yourself
today and find out how you can get three
months free at expressvpn dot-com slash
Theo
that's expr ESS VPN dot-com slash th EO
for three free months with a one-year
package visit Express VPN dot-com slash
Theo to learn more also if you're hiring
people it used to be hard multiple job
sites all these resumes what is this
this resume has coffee on it it's a
confusing review process but today
hiring can be easy and you only have to
go to one place to get it
zip recruiter dot-com slash tpw so Nick
if you ever don't work here anymore
that's where I'm gonna go find someone
nice pretty cool huh yeah but you can
find someone really quick well yeah
probably not as good as you that man
Thanks you see potential of me yeah dude
yeah sometimes I should probably express
that to you more zip recruiter sends
your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job
zip recruiter is so effective god it's
effective dude I mean it's like a Tony
Gwynn of helping you find somebody for
employment zip recruiter is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
and right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter dot-com / tpw
that's zip recruiter dot-com / t pw zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire man i
almost wanted to get some cocaine in las
vegas brah
that's the place I felt like you ever
walk past one of those places in there
cooking fudge in there and then put it
on the counter and they like cut it up
and there's like somebody's back there
by a big cattle I'm like they should
have one of those but for cocaine like
when you walk by in Vegas yeah I don't
even know the process of cocaine to be
educational to would be cool huh yeah
and they're back there that's listen to
some music beans don't burn on the grill
it took a whole trying it just to get up
a hill yeah man I'm I feel pretty
fortunate I fought the desire though
yeah glad you didn't damn bro I still
just want that white monkey to climb up
into my [ __ ] face bro but um anyhow
what else yeah this week I'll be in in
Memphis and a lot of shows man Memphis
Birmingham Atlanta Louisville and
somewhere else I don't even know that's
a crazy thing Memphis Thursday Friday
Saturday I don't even know it's like 10
shows this week all across the Southland
I'm definitely fired up I think almost
everything sold out except for the
second show in Biloxi in AH in
Birmingham uh do you think I recognize
your potential Nick or not yeah the
honest man I think so I mean I think
just in the position you gave me I mean
there's you need the potential to be
able to do do it so yeah I think so and
we talked about future plans and some of
the stuff we can accomplish so yeah that
gives me encouragement that you see it
in to me yeah cool man yeah but yeah
tell me more how much potential
let me think man I think I think you I
think you definitely exceed
my expectations oh thank you and I don't
mean that in a bad way or anything you
know uh but yeah I mean I think there's
times yeah you definitely exceed my
expectations when I know when I'm in a
place of like feeling grateful I usually
I often think man I'm grateful for Nick
you know oh thanks man
so the hard part for me sometimes is
just just getting in that place of
gratitude generally but I think when you
tell someone that they do have potential
to there's part of them like you on the
receiving end do it you want to live up
to that so it like makes you work harder
like you're like oh I better I better
live up to those expectations or
thoughts he has so you work harder so
yeah just in general telling that to
people can help yeah yeah yeah I could
see that yeah I could see that's
probably how like why some teachers are
good and stuff like that because when
they make a student feel that way I
think sometimes you just don't know like
what's you know sometimes you but
sometimes a teacher could say that a
million times you can say it for years
and none of them ever kind of cracked
the surface it just doesn't land mm-hmm
and then every now and then you'll it's
just it's almost like it has to be a
certain match up to between two people
and time you know when it when it really
when you're willing to hear it as well
and it really lands on you and you get
inspired I think also one thing we've
done and I think it's like each other
pushing each other this podcast keeps
evolving in a number of ways because
we're always it doesn't have to be the
same week to week and I think that's
that's part of it ya know what I mean
that's good to hear because I know yeah
it's like um yeah I think sometimes I
want to like try things different I get
like a little bit afraid I guess um but
yeah I think yeah there is some
evolution you know we've moved to some
different studios you know we've taken
you know it's a lot of times where all
does take your suggestion I feel like I
do you ever feel like you can't make
suggestions and stuff never that's
that's an awesome thing about working in
this environment yeah we can
say whatever they sometimes are you
sometimes they're not but I mean with
this whole studio like our layout and
stuff we that went back and forth and it
became it's mishmash of both our our
kind of visions for it yeah yeah that's
true huh it's taking a little bit longer
than I thought
it was it's been a learning process for
me just kind of a project management
like because like basically what's
holding us up now we've got construction
people ready to go put put in chords but
I'm trying to talk to engineers who were
taking longer than I thought and and in
the future that stuff before we even got
the contractor in here I would had
everything finished and that's like
what's holding us up at the moment but I
mean we're still functional but I want
to be like plug and play yeah and it
would make my job easier because we're
moving stuff back and forth for the
guest episodes the solo episodes and
stuff and eventually you'll get a lot
easier no that's good to hear man yeah I
think uh yeah it's um yeah it's been
crazy in here man it's but it definitely
been unique I mean it's just coming
along it's just and you've done a lot of
it man thank you very much no problem
all right let's get into a couple more a
couple more calls I'm sorry that I
forgot the computer today guys but I'm
glad we have a little bit of a change of
pace man it takes a little stress off of
me I've just been feeling stressed and
you know and I know I say that all the
time and it but some of us just like you
know once we started King in the sting
and then the you know doing this past
weekend twice a week sometimes with a
guess it's just a lot of output and then
in my head I started thinking man I'm
boring people and there's nothing to
talk about or so it's good to have a
change of pace you know and it's good to
have somebody in here and it's
interesting to talk about potential man
it's interesting to talk about you know
how you and I interact - we've never
really just we discuss it some but yes
sometimes if like I could do a better
job I mean I know like sometimes I'll
get pissed I'll wake up in the morning
pissed and the first person the only
person that works for me is you so first
I have [ __ ] it is you so I'm sure that
gets stressful man how what's that like
to deal with I kind of have like a a
mantra I'm like don't let other people's
mood affect mine like go in just go in
with the same attitude every day try to
try to be positive and like work
harder but like like I said don't don't
let other people's like energy mess up
my energy come in positive and like
focused yeah and and just do that
everyday kind of like you said you don't
last week it was all about expectations
and stuff and like I can't have
expectations for the people who work
around me I can just know if I'm doing
my job
sincerely I'm attempting the best I can
then I just got a letter stuff slide off
my back yeah well thanks for letting us
lot up your back sometimes man I usually
if I feel like I'm out of line I try to
come back and I feel like I usually get
around pretty quick on like bringing it
bringing that out yeah yeah and letting
you know if I felt like I was you know
you know rude or you know but yeah man
you're just like the only person who
might you know he's the closest person
in my life in some instances so you
[ __ ] got to hear all the [ __ ] I feel
you but I don't know I none of it is
like I put myself in your shoes like
your life is over the past eighteen
months like it it's it's [ __ ] it's
wild yeah it's good it's completely
different you like you sell like 150,000
tickets or whatever this month like yeah
this year this year and that's crazy
that that's a wild thought and like
looking at your tour schedule for fall
it's wild and I'm sure just looking at
what's ahead that is where the stress
comes from not as much as like what
you're doing in the moment it's just
knowing it's like a Sisyphean battle
always uphill yeah yeah it's always yeah
it's definitely been interesting and so
then it's just learning Who I am in
those spaces you know and learning like
you know and learning that there's some
things I like about me and those when
those as this things has gotten busier
and there's some things that I don't you
know one of the things though is
sometimes about the my mood the mood
that I wait you know when I get agitated
if things are in a certain way and stuff
but appreciate you putting up with me
man no problem but I definitely I see a
lot of your potential man and you know I
know I'm fortunate to be able to work
with you thanks brother I feel fortunate
as well I think you have the potential
to be the biggest comedy star in the
world
so thanks man only going up you're gonna
be selling out MSG like Sebastian what
monosodium glutamate
as [ __ ] this [ __ ] killing edges bro
you're gonna quit comedy and start
selling chemicals I could see that God
be good just roll around with a big tank
of it on the truck come over here boy
let me get a couple squirts this under
your tongue it sells itself yeah oh it's
so good dude if you order just MSG bro
from Israel or one of these other places
about [ __ ] the food man [ __ ] the bok
choy dog just put this [ __ ] under your
tongue dog and look for the Lord all
right let's take another question or two
man all right hey Theo um my name is
Sophia I was born with a condition that
affects every system of my body and I
have been chronically ill my entire life
oh god I think I had that I think it was
my mother actually when I was young and
now it's just myself bothering every
system on my body I'm sorry to hear
about that I appreciate your call and
thank you for sharing that with us
what's going on and some of the main
symptoms are overwhelming sadness and
anxiety and things that really keep me
from being able to socialize very well
and I'm about to go to a concert and I
have I don't get out of house much so I
I'm stressing being around people and
I'm fearing judgment I just watched your
podcast where you talked about thinking
about what other people are thinking
about you and when I go out in public I
had I have to do a lot of things to be
able to take care of myself and
sometimes I worry what other people
think of me and it's really stressful
so knowing you know that there's other
people out there that are going through
that same thing
goddamn to anybody else out there with
chronic illness whether or not you know
you have it what's going on in your body
know that you're not alone and that it's
always okay to express your emotions and
it's always okay to tell someone they
you have to step back set your
boundaries Thanks
much deal yeah door you say gang well
thanks for the sweet call yeah I could
definitely feel ya makes me it makes me
you know it makes me think that you're
pretty brave to call and share that you
know that takes a lot of bravery I mean
it makes you feel like you're on the
frontlines of your own emotions and
feelings and your battle in that and
that anxiety it's so tough you know you
go somewhere and you think that
everybody already doesn't like you
before they get there and they've
already made this decision in their in
their heads or you know you just get so
scared of like just being out and about
and you know I get scared to look in
people's eyes sometimes because I feel
like they knew that I was they could see
something inside of me that was wrong
and I didn't even know what it was and
or they could see that I was weak or I
don't know I just yeah I just I know
that that's really painful and I know
that that's really brave they love you
you know into to just say look you know
I'm still I'm gonna pack up Who I am and
I'm gonna go and I'm gonna go see this
band or I'm gonna go and and and apply
for this job or I'm gonna go and and uh
and I'm just gonna take action and you
know it's so funny when you we play the
beginning of the call again Nick hey
Theo um my name is Sophia I was born
with a condition that affects every
system of my body and I have been
chronically ill my entire life and some
of the main symptoms are overwhelming
sadness and anxiety and things that
really keep me from being able to
socialize very well and I'm about to go
to a concert and I don't get out of
house much so I I'm stressing being
around people and I'm fearing judgement
I just watched yeah if it's really
really hit you really hit me in the
heart right there yeah cuz you're just
fearing judgment and you know why it
kind of makes me sad I think when I
really think about it I can relate to
that but it also makes me sad because I
know that I'm judgmental sometimes you
know I know that I'm as much as I don't
want to be I am you know that I judge
others because it makes me feel a little
bit separate and that distance that
space gives me the space I need to then
put up my garden to be okay you know and
uh you know and you calling and saying
that I think it reminds me that that I
can always be of service somehow if I'm
at a concert if I'm walking down the
hall if I am no matter what I'm doing I
can always be of service to someone or I
always there's always an opportunity
because there's you're probably gonna be
you know a lot of other people at the
concert and none of them may know what
you're going through may know but some
of that somebody may get a feeling when
they're around you oh maybe I should
just check in with this person see how
they're doing or just you know it's like
you know you are an opportunity for
other people to express the best part of
themselves you know a part that's very
caring and man what if God made you as a
gift like a you God made you as this
basically this opportunity that's
wandering around you know that you have
this opportunity like you are this
opportunity then when people you know
when people care and show that you know
reach out to you or somebody like you or
just let help you to feel okay that that
they are thing and it feels so good
about themselves and so that's really
wild because you that's like a you have
the potential oddly to make people feel
really good because if people know that
you're struggling and then they are
they're able to you know just
be a part of a little bit more your joy
or comfort and that's really gonna make
them realize a potential that they
didn't have inside of themselves um what
do you think Nick yeah she has the
potential to make other people feel good
about themselves and other people who
are in her same position her facing
these fears and going out into public it
shows other people who are suffering
from whatever she is that they can do it
to and you can live a fulfilling life
and not let whatever ailment you have
hold you back yeah yeah it's so crazy
how we've gotten so trapped inside of
ourselves a little bit you know I do
believe that the cure-all for everything
can be helping others and if you can
find a way in your life and even in
those moments when you are struggling
the most and most anxious and everything
to just try and be helpful to someone
else that I think for it can offer you
some peace where you were we don't think
about ourselves you know when we're
thinking about somebody else it's really
hard to think about ourselves um it's
really almost impossible but yeah I'll
just appreciate I just appreciate you
calling because you know you dis
reminded me of feelings you reminded me
of feelings and that people have them
and that we're all struggling somehow
you know we're all struggling we're all
struggling somehow and for you to be
brave enough to say that and share it
and for some reason in some weird space
inside of me or not even a weird space
but an okay space it makes me feel like
there's hope you know it makes me feel
hopeful because if you can share that
you feel that way then then I know that
it's okay for me to feel that way a
little bit and when I acknowledge that I
feel sometimes like so worried about
what other people are thinking or I feel
so afraid or I feel you know like people
are judging me so much and there's
nothing that I can do that's ever gonna
make me feel okay
when I feel those you know when I feel
so
those things that and I lost my train of
thought but I really was enjoying being
on the tracks um when you share that
you're not feeling well it activates a
part of me inside of me that also has
the same fears and same uncertainty and
maybe not the same level of illness that
you suffer from but part of it a little
of it I can really relate and when I can
relate it makes me feel not alone and so
thank you because you did that for me a
little bit you know you you made me feel
a little bit more okay to to be brave
even if I'm not okay
you're a sweetheart and I hope you had
fun at the concert and when I come close
I hope you'll come out and be my guest
at my show and uh and just thank you
because you just I just needed something
today to make my life feel you know I
know it's selfish but I just needed
something to remind me about what's
important and that's each other and um
and you just did that for me so man or
lady sorry
you you're doing more than you know
be good to yourself you know you deserve
it I know that and I'm gonna try doing
the same thing for myself and we can do
it you know we can do it that's kind of
the episode I guess today Nick how do
you feel man thanks for coming in here I
thought it was great
yeah lots of feeling yeah lots of
important stuff and I need this you know
and I'm so grateful that uh you know I'm
just I don't know what I'm trying to
figure out a little bit one of my
feelings from that girl's call
well I guess
just amazing it's like you know a whole
you know an hour of chatting and this
and that and and the thing that really
just Vives
the the vibration really you know I
really got something whenever we're
whenever I was listening to her call you
know just kind of made me feel something
that's powerful it's so powerful that we
can that that that can happen even
through electronics and everything you
know through a voicemail not even
through them actual you know in person
touch interaction that you can feel
people's feelings you know that
transmission that's powerful you know
the power of just each other it's very
very powerful man we've got a lot of
potential here in this podcast only knit
yes we do and we're lucky to have it and
that's us and that's you and that's
everybody so be good to yourselves gang
and uh I'm gonna go eat some dinner dude
and get some rest bro
you feel me what are you gonna do Nick
I'm gonna edit this episode unlimited
potential here in this guy man and he
was premature man and he frickin
exceeded expectations dude the guy was
in the incubator for how long dude good
good three weeks believable brother
unbelievable everybody knew her from now
from around there man against all odds
against haha that's bro do you remember
that movie about the black football
player when we were young it was on all
the time it was on all the time it was
like Larry gray or something it was like
Mario Van Peebles played in it no god it
was good what was that movie it was on
all the time man
and he was like against all odds radio
know are you comparing me to radio man
well maybe so that got a lot of his head
so bro yeah dude we all got some popcorn
in this man you know we all got some
popcorn they don't see it then we'll see
look they think we just a little yellow
chunk bro let him see that but BAM bro
what's up you know what I'm saying
Orvil red and knock our dog you know
what I'm saying I'm at your door baby
with capabilities and uh we'll go out
with some with let's go out with uh
making it by Bishop gun and gang gonna
be good yourselves
[Music]
bacon
and most all of my plans slip right
through my hands and whack up next to me
[Music]
spiral wasn't our glance I'm slaving I'm
about it I will cast a minute I should
have put it
[Music]
but how
bacon
[Music]
[Applause]
but I'm importing good scream for the
shave
[Music]
I hate seen old mandala vulture date I
can almost hear mama peep from our
recipes
[Music]
you